é
les marchés financiers.
Le choc boursier a été de courte
durée, mais l'événement a
accéléré certains changements
dans l'économie américaine.
Marie-Claude Morin.
(sirènes)
- Les attentats du 11 septembre
ont frappé New York en plein
coeur de ses activités,
causant même la fermeture
complète de ses bourses.
- L'aspect dramatique
de ce qui s'est passé
a très largement dominé.
Nous avions quand même
des centaines de morts,
nous avons eu le problème,
par exemple, d'un manque
de sang.
- Dans le contexte, les parquets
new-yorkais ont décidé de fermer
pendant toute une semaine,
du jamais-vu dans l'histoire.
- Un certain nombre d'opérateurs
et leurs clients n'auraient
pas été en mesure d'agir sur
la Bourse, alors que d'autres
auraient pu le faire. Ça aurait
créé une inégalité qui était
totalement inacceptable.
♪ ♪ ♪
- La réouverture,
le 17 septembre, a suscité
beaucoup d'émotions.
- À la fois une tristesse
profonde de ce qui s'était
passé, mais j'allais
dire une rage de vivre,
un besoin de recommencer.
Nous ne pouvions pas
nous laisser abattre.
Il fallait remettre
les marchés en route,
il fallait que l'économie
se remette en route.
- Mais avec l'incertitude,
le Dow Jones a perdu 7 %
la première journée et
plus de 14 % durant la semaine.
- Les chocs dans l'histoire,
c'est pas le premier puis
ce sera pas le dernier,
comme on vient de le vivre
et on est en train de le vivre.
Tous les chocs sont similaires,
surprenants, imprévus et...
créent de l'instabilité.
- En fait, les marchés
étaient déjà en correction
avec l'éclatement de
la bulle technologique.
- L'événement a servi de
catalyseur ou d'accélérateur
de la correction.
Quand un événement comme ça
arrive, concentrez-vous sur
des bonnes compagnies parce que
les bonnes compagnies finissent
par passer à travers. C'est ça
que vous voulez, c'est passer
à travers la tempête.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Un mois plus tard, les indices
étaient déjà revenus au niveau
d'avant les attentats, entre
autres grâce à l'intervention
musclée de la Réserve fédérale
américaine, qui a réduit
les taux d'intérêt et,
surtout, injecté 200 milliards
de liquidités dans le système.
- Tout ça, ça a fait en sorte
de créer une confiance sur
les marchés qui a évité que
ça tourne en quelque chose
de plus grave. Je pense
qu'ils ont été très efficaces.
- Les compagnies aériennes,
elles, ont vu le trafic aérien
plonger de 35 % aux États-Unis.
- Aujourd'hui, quand
on le compare avec la pandémie,
ça nous paraît moins important,
mais n'empêche qu'à l'époque,
on n'avait jamais connu
un tel effondrement et
on ne savait pas quoi faire
face à cet effondrement-là.
- D'ailleurs, à peine deux
semaines après les attentats,
le Congrès accordait
une aide de 15 milliards
à l'industrie aérienne.
- La majorité de ces compagnies,
qui ont dit qu'elles étaient en
difficulté, qui ont demandé de
l'aide du gouvernement fédéral
à l'époque, elles étaient déjà
en situation de difficulté
financière avant les attentats.
- Tous secteurs confondus,
près de 200 000 Américains
ont perdu leur emploi
après les attentats.
Mais quelques mois plus tard,
l'économie s'était déjà relevée.
- L'effet a pas été persistant.
Donc, c'est un choc qui était
concentré dans le temps,
qui était... L'impact pour
la ville de New York a été
beaucoup plus important,
évidemment, mais pour
l'économie en général, mondiale
et certainement les États-Unis,
ça a été... plus contenu.
- La relance américaine a,
par contre, amené certains
changements structuraux
dans l'économie.
- Les attaques du 11 septembre
ont accéléré peut-être
des phénomènes qui allaient
se produire de toute façon,
mais ils les ont certainement
accélérés. 2001, c'est
une récession de profits.
Les entreprises devaient
trouver une solution pour...
raviver les profits,
et une des solutions,
c'est d'utiliser l'entrée
de la Chine dans l'OMC pour
faire une relocalisation
de la production.
- Washington s'est aussi lancée
dans une déréglementation
pour favoriser la relance.
- Ça a peut-être mené à certains
excès que l'on a connus en 2005-
2006, d'innovations financières
qui étaient moins encadrées,
et qui a mené à cette...
à la récession de 2007-2008,
soit la grande récession.
- Sans oublier que
les États-Unis ont dépensé,
depuis 2001, 6000 millards
de dollars pour la sécurité
intérieure et la lutte
contre le terrorisme.
Ici Marie-Claude Morin,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.